monsieur vous êtes prêt à coucher avec
moi pour avoir un rôle oui mais alors là
je crains fort que vous soit pour vous
la dernière fois que vous couchez avec
quelqu'un
[Musique]
parce que vous ne voulez pas le noir
dans le cinéma je suis comédien et
contraint de faire depuis des années de
faire la figuration c'est un métier où
il y a ça pardonne pas j'y crois c'est
pour ça que je suis là et je
voudrais
[Musique]
vous les apercevez souvent dans les
films mais vous ne les connaissez pas ce
sont les figurants ils sont embauchés
sur les tournages par des chefs de fil
j'ai 4500 photos et il y a à peu près du
travail pour 10% de personnes
vous avez
par exemple des
prostituées je vous
demande
pas
des
des gens de couleur
vous devez regarder par terre alors vous
y allez mais vraiment c'est punk
absolument j'en ai fourni un
dernièrement
[Musique]
au sol
j'ai tout j'ai tout absolument tout
la distribution est terminée
[Musique]
bonjour mesdames
et pour moi madame vous avez pas dit
quelque chose une petite frime
marseillais par exemple
c'est-à-dire que je l'ai présenté votre
fils à l'employeur le rôle du
journaliste américain
vous pouvez pas leur dire que je suis à
peu près comme il faut
dans les trois à plus de personnes dans
le fichiers ce sont des danseurs des
chanteurs des musiciens donc des gens du
spectacle qui avant n'avaient pas besoin
de figuration du tout et maintenant bah
alors c'est pas un peu dévalorisant de
faire des petits rôles
de pouvoir pour la cité sociale pour
avoir des nouvelles Assedic donc c'est
très utile qu'on a refaites aussi
quelques personnes qui pleuraient même
fait ça gratuitement pour avoir sa
retraite bonjour vous êtes l'assistant
de la production
il y a pas un petit rôle pour moi
un petit annonce et vous espérez trouver
quoi alors ici j'espère pas je souhaite
je veux je désire
bon nous on cherche des figurants en
plus des dossiers de la SFP et de la NPE
et tous les dossiers on cherche des
figurants un peu avec des têtes
nouvelles donc moi je suis très
disponible en ce moment alors vous me
laissez une photo voilà et puis vous
remplissez cette feuille
avec le nom l'adresse au téléphone et la
date de naissance
comme mon cas personnel c'était quelque
chose d'atroce au début je n'avais pas
les moyens nécessaires pour rentrer dans
un cours
on me demandait 500 francs par mois
parce que vraiment j'ai vu des années où
je ne faisais pas plus de 300 000 francs
ancien par tête chez moi à 7h du matin
pour être la première partout c'était
fermé ou c'était reporté à une autre
date ou ailleurs ou enfin c'était
quelque chose d'épouvantable il fallait
toujours que je cours que je descende
que j'en arrivais à
craindre qu'on appelle tellement j'étais
fatiguée mais alors pourquoi vous faites
ce métier
est-ce que ça me plaît
ça c'est ça Loïc
ça me plaît
voir à l'image
non de tourner j'aime tourner même si on
ne boit pas les mains ça m'est égal mais
l'ambiance
j'adore l'ambiance
les metteur en scène les assistantes
tout le monde la musique des fois les
décors les décors c'est quelquefois
c'est tellement somptueux c'est
tellement bon que ça fait rêver et c'est
tellement merveilleux parce que c'est
que
[Musique]
tous les jours non plus mais c'est vrai
qu'un il y a un peu un fossé social quoi
si vous voulez si on prend par exemple
d'une journée comme aujourd'hui il fait
froid par exemple tout le monde a froid
mais pour les acteurs il y a quand même
un certain nombre d'aménagements
relativement respectés et pour la
figuration on le fait pas c'est
probablement parce que c'est pas
possible parce qu'il y en a trop aussi
c'est ça pose des vrais problèmes mais
il y a quand même il me semble une vraie
différence sociale comme il y a une
différence de classe sociale qu'on le
veuille ou non et je pense que ça existe
ça entre la manière dont on traite les
acteurs quand on les traite bien et la
manière dont on traite les figurants en
général on traite pas très bien faut
bien le dire comme une espèce de groupe
anonyme
[Musique]
tout seul
là on assiste
[Musique]
on a tourné Colette ensemble alors là je
faisais un genre de diplôme
et vous êtes là depuis ce matin
j'espère que ça continuera pourquoi pas
vous avez pas de texte aujourd'hui
malheureusement
parce que c'est pas la même tarif et
tout le monde est sensible au
tarés sont les figurants
font du syndicalisme c'est-à-dire c'est
le groupe des figurants professionnels
qui monopolisent le métier de figuration
et qui empêche les jeunes acteurs de
faire de la figuration si vous avez été
vu un certain nombre de fois en tant que
acteurs de complément pour employer ce
mot
c'est comme comédien car vous êtes
catalogué dans les figurants vous faites
de la figuration mais sur les comédiens
soyez sûr vous allez être grillés dans
le cinéma les figurants qui désiraient
être payé s'il vous plaît
les acteurs de complément pardon
la figuration s'est bien payée il paraît
absolument
[Musique]
on sera engagé si on dit du mal c'est à
dire si on dit la vérité on sera pas
engagé
[Musique]
si un chef de fil a une fille bon qu'il
a envie de faire plus ample connaissance
et il a il a fait travailler même si
elle est pas dans le qu'est-ce que vous
entendez par là par là bon bah pour être
plus précis de pour coucher avec voilà
là je suis précis il faut fréquenter les
gens il faut il faut connaître les gens
de la accoucher systématiquement non je
pense pas
j'essaie de me persuader que l'on a pas
besoin de passer par là mais je pense
que
il y a encore un stéréotype une image on
dit il faut coucher avec tout le monde
pour arriver à quelque chose donner
comme on dit régulièrement son voilà
pour arriver à quelque chose et ben là
je sais même pas la peine de continuer
de ce côté là je préfère reprendre la
valise et me tirer ce que vous êtes
prête à coucher avec moi pour avoir un
rôle
monsieur vous êtes prêt à coucher avec
moi pour avoir un rôle oui mais alors là
je crains fort que vous soit pour vous
la dernière fois que vous coucher avec
quelqu'un
d'abus que voulez-vous qui est comme
abuses surtout des
chefs de fil
[Musique]
passe je te dis pas que c'est vraiment
l'idéal mais enfin un machin comme ça et
j'ai regardé la caméra tout de suite à
la première minute donc pas conséquent
j'ai été viré à la deuxième minute donc
j'ai fait deux minutes de figuration
dans ma vie je me souviens d'avoir fait
il y a très longtemps en 1751 et on
mangeait avec Abel grand
mais je tombe je suis pas de faire
quelque chose quoi il fait froid
c'est bien c'est marrant
pour moi
il y a pas un petit rond pour moi là
[Applaudissements]
il y a pas un rôle pour moi
[Musique]